[Music]
hello everbody my name is Vitaly Nomura
and I'm the game master resident here
the same who is chess club today our
lecture is going to be play like a pro
and although I do consider myself as a
as a pro and lots of members of the club
requested to see some of my games
however due to recent events I would
like to feature a good friend of our in
a member of our club and a guy named
named Fabi
who probably heard him some he played
somebody wants something so I think if
he's pretty close to being a pro I think
that every everybody agrees not today so
what would be better
then then to discuss the you know the
upcoming match that party match is going
to be held in London in November so
Fabiano is going to have lots of time to
prepare so that makes it eight months
and yeah it's it's it's gonna be
interesting how I think that every world
champion has its own approach how many
games to play before how many games you
know how many seconds or you know
coaches even even elite players like
Khurana and you know Carlsen they also
have coaches which is kind of strange
because you might people ask you know
wait a second other Island did the best
in the world
well yeah well the best of the world
will still need T to to practice and
being coached that's that's why they are
the best in the world so in that case we
called the coaches seconds so they're
kind of the players who assist them in
the game Dianna they analyzed some some
lines usually the second day they're
kept kept in a secret
anybody knows why do we keep the seconds
as a secret why nobody reveals this the
the seconds exactly yes so usually when
you hire somebody besides the fact that
he's a very strong chess player every
every chess player has its own unique
specialities
strategies some people are more tactical
some people are more positional but
especially it's about the openings so
every every player has its own opening
repertoire and so you don't want for
example to to get all of your coaches
just on one opening and maybe you want
to to try to change those openings but
basically if I know who you who your
coaches are and then I know what what
they are playing and thus I know what
you might be playing against in the
world champion so so that that's
probably gonna be kept as a secret so
okay so it's gonna be in London as we
said I mean that the match is probably
gonna be pretty much the same format as
it was before 12 games and yeah it's
gonna put interesting so so far the the
classical the classical result between
all types of between Magnus Carlsen and
Fabiana Khurana is 9:00 to 5:00 in the
fable of carp Magnus they also had a
pretty there dead a few draws more
precisely if I'm not mistaken 17 draws
so I would expect to see lots of drawers
but this is pretty much expected in
those kinds of levels but so far you
know Magnus Carlsen has the the upper
hand in the classical matches a but on
the other hand the Khurana has the
momentum remember that he was it was
asked in the press conference he was you
know what do you have anything you know
anything to you know to say to Magnus
and then the next question the
interviewer asked him if you know is
Magnus happy about that about the result
of the two limited Fabiano that he did
he won the tournament and Fabi said that
well maybe maybe he's actually wood so
anyway so today I wanted to show you a
game that Khurana played and beat
Karlsson it was not too much of a long
ago and he beat him with the black
pieces which you know which pretty
important you know so if you if you can
beat somebody with the black pieces it
definitely shows that you can become in
a match right if you beat him once you
can do it again
so let's see what what what happened in
the game the game itself happened right
here in the st. Louis chess club at our
most famous tournament the Sinquefield
Cup this game is from 2014 and not not
so long ago
okay so Towson played plays with the
white pieces and Magnus starts with with
a movie for so the movie for is featured
and as you know Khurana is playing the
move e5 this is a favorite response
against efore and Qasim decides to
deviate from the usual night of tea and
he plays this move Bishop to c4 this
this opening has a very unique name it's
called the bishop opening ok I guess
people people really really original in
their names Bishop c4 well so what's the
point of this move Bishop c4 it's not
revealing exactly whites whites ideas
for example I actually used to play the
few times would white myself one of the
ideas of not putting the the night here
on f3 is that white can't play d3 and
then to play a four it's kind of the for
example let's say I play 96 I can play
d3 let's say black plays passe move
Bishop you say e 7 and now boy plays f4
d6 and now Knight f3 so pretty much it
resembles the King's gambit just without
the the pawn sacrifice because if it
takes on therefore that the bishop can
take on the 4 so this is pretty much the
idea of the bishops opening okay so the
main move against the bishops opening is
oh also I forgot to mention that
obviously
on 96 you know Magnus can try to
collimate Fabian I don't know maybe
maybe this was his intention so who
knows we never know we will never know
because Fabiano played this very strong
move Knight f6 which prevents both of
the Scala made ideas Queen f3 and queen
h5 so I mean he was prepared that's
that's why we one of them you know first
lesson did you learn how to prevent the
skulls made exactly deep opening
preparation and DT was played and as I
said you know if black plays 96 then
sometimes what can they have this idea
so therefore so here karana is is
playing the main line falling the main
line which is c6 and obviously the idea
of c6 is to play this move d5 Knight f3
now now f4 would be very very bad
because now black would play still
probably just d5 and if we look at the
the Kings gambit for white when white
plays the move equally 5f4 besides
taking on the 4 black also can play this
this move d5 this is called the marshals
cantle gambit in the Kings in D in the
Kings gambit also very very popular
so here the the the basic idea is that
okay if he is exposing his King on the
flank which is going to punch him in the
center and it this works trust me
okay so so white has to play now Knight
f3 finally and black is playing d5 now
by the way if black wants he can play
Bishop e7 he's not too worried about
white taking this this pawn here because
black can simply go to a5 and and
capture this night that's that's a
no-brainer but again d5 is just a more
logical move okay so why to move do we
take this pawn on d5 or do we go back
what do we do yeah so why to move dude
that's why to take on the on on d5 oh it
goes back true correct so you don't want
to take on d5 because that's only going
to improve the exposition allowed the
night clip to come to Lucy six and
you're opening up your king so Bishop to
b3
okay well Bishop to b3 though can't
can't like just take you on on e4 and if
you take me and want to take your queen
here on d1 then what take on e4 and then
what take on f2 what was it for so what
what's the probability it D takes e4
Knight takes e5 Oh
if the knight takes on e5 then we have
Queen a5 yes exactly and this in this
case if pawn takes here not to take here
because of this trick but Knight to the
other side Knight to g5 and here the
game can can be very very sharp like an
auto try to take here but usually they
play something like Bishop three six and
the white can decide you can either take
with an eye toward the bishop but just
for example if it takes to the bishop
take now we can exchange bunch of pieces
and white will be having the upper hand
because of the very very nice pawn
structure those points going to become
witnesses in the future so so this is
why taking only four is is not good so
it's I guess it's a minor trap but what
to do with black well you know really
Fabiana found a very good movie with
black within a I would give it an
exclamation mark so try to think about
it so black to move so there's the
simple way just to defend the e5 pawn 95
okay yeah so the question is you know
how do we defend this pawn on d5 because
why it simply wants to the castle and
you know I tagged this pawn on e5 so
there are a few ways or somewhere we can
play 97 you can play Bishop g4 come play
Bishop d6 oh and somebody suggested here
Bishop to b4 check Bishop reform is
actually not defending the pawn but
let's look at the other ideas first if
Bishop to g4 then he can play h3 and
then we have to figure out what to do
with this Bishop do we really want to
take it for exchange for the night
because otherwise something like this
might happen and I'm not
if it's good or bad but what might
happen in the future also the Bishop
Knight to d7 slightly doesn't look so
logical to me because it's blocking my
Bishop and the Queen and I know that I
will need them in the game so in the
game if I be able did play this move
external Bishop to b4 check so you
create good job you you're guessing all
of his moves today are you need second
don't tell us I wasn't gonna be
researching openings oh we can bribe him
right okay so Bishop to b4 check what's
the idea of this move well it basically
asks white to commit to some move and
white can play 93 Bishop d2 or c3 Knight
c2 is impossible because of d4 obviously
so I'm going to lead this one but
basically it commits why to play 2
playing something for example if black
instead would play Bishop d6 instead
well wife can simply play 93 and here's
a nice nice position so instead of
please please check a check first city
is being played if they usually the
movement now Bishop to d6 Bishop to g5
the idea of the move is now the knight
is pinned and now whitey wants to take
it on d5 so we have to to respond to
this and the black takes only four takes
now h6 so as you can see in all of those
positions what is so interesting is it's
almost it looks like black is slightly
worse because I'm playing black but he
also delays the his castle is as much as
possible pretty much what he did with
against Greece Chuck so you place HH 6
first just asking the bishop hey where
are you going you're keeping with it
with a pin here by playing Bishop h4
you're gonna take on f6 so you're gonna
go back to some somewhere else so that's
a good probing move for for black the
bishop went to h4 and still he does not
castle
but he plays the smoke Queen to e7 this
is kind of a very favorite move of his
this move 27 and then moving the Queen
somewhere very interesting an IBD 2
diabetes 7 still no castle
and now Magnus played this move Bishop
to e3 I'm not sure that this this move
was really necessary for white to play
because the bishop on h4 looks looks
pretty good but I think maybe at some
point maybe Magnus was was concerned
about black 25 and and starting some
attack on the or the Kings side while
they can cast alongside it's very hard
to tell the good thing about Bishop to
d3 is that if cait's lots and lots of
pressure on this on this pawn on e5
for example black's one of blacks ideas
in this position was to play this move
97 and then Knight f8 and a 96 this is a
very famous plan in the Louie Lopez that
we see for white is doing many times
kind of the same way both of the players
actually do it in the air on their own
so the idea of Bishop to g3 is that now
black cannot play this this move a
knight of fate so what's the proud of
this move Knight to f8 so white to move
here yeah so here so this this is
correct so soon he'll just simply Knight
to c4 if you take only Ford and I can
part the public at the castle or take on
d6 so so this is not possible here this
move Knight Knight to f8 so Bishop to g3
was played now black plays this move
Bishop to c7 and now white castles okay
well now I've hidden my bishop on c7
what if I try a knight if neither faith
here
so my plan is 96 Bishop somebody six o
g4 and then I just want a long castle
and then make you just just F an FYI so
why to move why not why why not if F a
testbed is a bad move flee the boss for
you guys so you won't go for it you
won't go for this for the sacrifice
come on was your fighting spirit C -
yeah that's that's fine but then then
you don't prevent my plan 96 will
develop my bishop then maybe Castle
longside o castle short side it's quite
strange to see those the difference
between those bishops is because that
that's what was the difference in the
position my bishops blacks bishops has
just tucked in all defended on the door
that side and while White's bishops are
much much more active but it doesn't
mean that we're there much worse
so in this position the best move for
white
yeah neither is form I'm not
knowledgeful
is probably possible and then night at
five it's a nice jump not sure I'm not
sure exactly what to do maybe maybe just
g6 but yeah that's that's that's a
that's an interesting option so so the
idea was actually correct it's just to
sacrifice the only five
now it takes Bishop takes Bishop takes
Queen takes and now ninety four and we
cannot take only four because the rocky
one obviously over ninety six right even
better so Queen c7
and now we have 96 check the King became
probably does not want to go only to the
D file because it's gonna be some kind
of a discovered check on f7 maybe I'll
be five and so King is seven and here we
have lots of choices we can either just
take here on f7 or maybe just play e5
and see what happens and this is looks
pretty pretty bad for for for black
everything is exposed so that's the
difference this is why we can't play
knight Knight to to f8 instead black has
heard you idea with with Knight h4 he
played nine h5 himself and so it's it's
funny how those those bishops are
developed White has developed his
bishops but now black black is coming
for them okay what what to do here with
with white what would you guys play here
with white I think I think that in this
in this position is where Magnus Carlsen
made his first inaccuracy I would say
I guess this is just a night 85
okay here
I am
yeah it's two pieces for a rope and two
pawns actually it's not as bad as I
thought but I wonder if I have some I
wonder if I miss something like
something like Queen d6 or something
yeah maybe that's what I mean I'm
missing maybe Queen d6 yes you know take
the 92 check I can take all of our
pieces I'm just adjusting this one point
one point can be both what half a
million dollars or a million dollars
yeah so no it wasn't Knight takes e5 so
so in the game Magnus played this move
h3 which which is quite quite strange
because we don't really need this this
this movie hd and it also weakens the
the bishop right yes that's correct
so the correct way to play here for
white is just not to go too crazy but
you can just play this move Knight c4 if
we discussed before and for example
Knight xg3
porn hdgt usually we want to to take
towards the center unless really we know
that their file isn't going to be
important but you know if we put the
pawn here on H 2 then the e4 pawn is
going to be weak in the in the future
and have to take let's say castles now
white can make this interesting move
Knight to e3
releasing his bishop and at the same
time you know coming here to visit on
the 5 so I think this this is this is
quite quite equal position but instead
White Way this move h3 which in the in
well immediately Fabiano to con on g3
takes and now he played nine to c5 ok so
in this position you could also Castle
for example and yeah if you
wanted to 935 okay why to move I know
that's Fabiana won this game
however he really needed to find a very
good defense against necklaces attack it
doesn't look like Magnus's much like
this all of his pieces of wait how are
barely crossing the third-ranked so how
can you attack the skin on the 8th the
game is so safe and but like it's two
bishops the Queen is just next to him
but he finds a very an amazing plan but
very risky yes
why to play
correct Bishop takes of seven yeah and
so the problem is is that if we take
with the Queen the Knight takes e5 and
Queenie seven crap Queen h5 and complete
disaster so on Bishop takes of seven
black needs to take for their king he's
not afraid he's not not Bobby's not
afraid of Magnus and not afraid to lose
that's that's actually a very important
quality in in the world champion so nice
so King takes under seven nine takes
twenty five that's correct check well
the King has to go to g8 that's pretty
much the only spot again if I go to he's
six all ei then the queen is gonna hunt
us so we need to at least attack try to
talk out our king here it's important
that the knight on c5 the last move is
defending those important squares like
b3 form the Queen yes and there is no
likes prohibition that's correct
okay ninety-six attacking that Queen
well we need to move so the Queen goes
to g5 so far make sense and now Magnus
did the crack the crack of rook to F a
check why why is night X which eight is
so bad here okay which which which one
Bishop takes a stick Queen g3 or queen
e3 oh no nobody wants to take the knight
on a cheat
okay he's dead anyway he's resting we
have lots of checks but they it's
something to work
it's I remember it this is the regular
chest it's under D the three check
winches variation city on g3o Bishop
theta-c yes that's correct yeah because
I think that again if Queen to g2 g3 it
allows white to bring his pieces and
then just defend so he's to start with
this amazing move Bishop takes on h3 and
now obviously we want to take on the on
g3 and we're going to have a double
attack and you cannot take the bishop
because of this just this checkmate in
win in one move two moves if white tries
to defend with this move Queen to f3
then we can simply just go back and
right now we defend it with our rook the
bishop is defended everybody is all
defender than this Knight is just gonna
be gone possible by the way this Knight
and d2 is attacked so calcium makes the
correct move rook to f8 check okay we
have to go to h7 and now the question is
who needs to take the rook on h8 the
night or the rock
so both of the captions on the h8 are
possible and mangoes decided to take
with the night but I think that's
because they missed the next move the
black head it could also take with the
rook for example rook takes HH at King
takes here
Knight f2e lots of threads like night
like I think they're the Queen Queen III
check King h1 Knight takes e4 Knight is
full check King g5 check again King f6
we have some we can trade so Queens take
take a king to g1 and okay what do we
have here we have two bishops for a rook
but I think that that position is still
unclear we still need to get those
bishops out somehow and this the skiing
is a little bit shaky so this is very
very unclear position so I'm not not
sure but this could have happened in the
game instead Magnus decided to take with
the rook I'm sorry with a knight on a
chase and he missed blacks next move the
double extra move that you can find it
Bishop h3 and if I play Queen f3 I also
take their up
aking a one
neither flee
hmm yeah that's what they said that
actually might work so what did that go
around Queen 80 maybe King f1 yeah so
here immediately black is to play Bishop
g4 and this this this is also pretty
interesting a Bishop Bishop h3 that I
think Queen of three is the move and
take sake here Quinn back check here
check
oops check here and it seems like why
doesn't why this okay because if you if
you take on g2 I can take your queen
yeah very complicated anyway so in the
game if I we played Bishop to g4 a nice
discovered attack suddenly that was the
problem
so Bishop to g4 Queen to f1 and now
Knight to d3
well that is that if you take my
Brooklyn on on a8 then I can follow up
with some some checks and take here all
night of - that's a very nice move
93 quintet had to take on d3 rook takes
H takes d4 and again Bobby doesn't take
this knife and h8 but it just takes the
pawn g4 exactly Knight to f3 Quinta is
g3 so picks up all the points if I've
checked White has to play this move
otherwise this diagonal is just too
risky for him so if I've checked
now it takes well he forced us what can
you do
so King takes a 6 check what a white
king is just too exposed
King h1 and now
Fabrice simply plays this move Queen to
g4 you know the idea is to just to take
up the pawn if the ball goes to e7 which
would did not have been the game the
rook can simply go here and if you
defend the pawn I can check
9h - and now Bishop c7 and white can't
defend still or jittery for example but
then after Queen f7 we gotta get this
pawn once we gonna get this pawn then
yeah here's no he has no chance with
such a weak King and upon down so in
this position instead of playing e7 if
it Queen to d6
attack in the rock rock d8 Quinny 5 root
D 5 nice elevator trick queen-to-be 8
check King age seven and seven
whoa almost a queen it's almost there so
what to do now
do we check on age five with the Queen
or do we check on it five of the rock
so who is gonna come here okay well one
for the Rope one for the Queen so far
it's a tie
okay so we have two for the Queen one
for the rock yeah so that's exactly what
happened in the game so we need to quit
to check with the Queen if we check with
the rook then this is the size of
mistake because now night eh - there is
no way - to stop there the promotion of
the new queen so the Queen now is
defending the sides and no no tricks on
the back rank and so the idea is that
the Queen has to go to h5 check and here
Magnus made a decisive mistake probably
time pressure and he defended with the
night
ouch yeah the correct was to defend it
with the Queen and now yeah you guys are
correct so now we don't want to change
the Queen's but Queenie eight and the
game continues still black is probably
better although this pawn is it's
dangerous but I think that we eventually
we're gonna get it with the DOS two
moves that get this pawn but it's going
to take us a while in the game Magnus
played night 2 h2 and this is losing
because of rook to d1 take take knight
of one take and King to h2 and now the
last the last move in the game was
played and Fabiano made his worst
mistake so what is the correct moment
what was his mistake anybody knows
is it the correct of the mistake you
guys are quite so Bishop g1 was the
correct move because then if the kid if
the if the King goes to let's say h3 the
Queen a5 check g4 and we ever made in
the few moves check and checkmate
and if he goes to h1 check and check get
the Queen but instead in this position
he played Queen to g1 just going form
from eco it could get like minus 50
minus 15 on the computer engine it just
went for the pony 7 but Magnus no signs
so though his voice is lost moving again
that his worst mistake was that the the
last move of the game but obviously it's
it's still winning and so and good job
Bobby this is only tells us that if if
he can do it with black he can win the
championship and yeah so congratulation
to him and good luck in the world in the
championship this was a international
master of Italian a man from the same
Jewish chess club thank you for joining
us
[Music]